I'm 25 years old,...
...I live in Los Angeles, and I design socks for a living.
They're cut and sew, which is different than most socks.
It creates these like really beautiful seams on the back of the foot and around the foot.
I'm happy that I get to do what I want to do,...
...and stressed out whether or not it's actually gonna work out.
When I was at a bar with my friends dancing and I was really drunk,...
...and I dropped my phone into the toilet.
And when I fished it out, I rinsed it off with water...
...and I put it in a bag of rice to try to save it.
And it totally worked, but the only thing that was wrong with the phone...
...is it would repeatedly text people the letter P.
And so I thought it was kind of ironic that I like dropped it in pee.
It was texting people P.
You know what I mean?